[Music]
your first project
holds the promise of the new technology
you're introducing to your organization
if selected and executed well it can be
a showcase
that makes it easier to achieve repeated
success with subsequent programs of work
every business is competing in a digital
landscape irrespective of the industry
in our modern digital age speed is key
speed gives the ability to respond to
business challenges and opportunities
with digital solutions quickly
and at scale your ability to quickly
build and manage apis
with apogee is a key tool for success
your first delivery needs to demonstrate
and validate to your organization your
ability to deliver at speed
something that matters to the company we
call this delivery
the minimum viable business outcome
your mvbo is an early win that delivers
apis
that are core to your business and
creates early momentum
with a pathway for its repeated success
driving for many years of working with
enterprise customers
to help them with delivering on their
api programs we've seen
patterns that typically lead to
increased risk of failure
or the transformation program stalling
out
let's take a look typical adoption
patterns look like an s-curve
as shown here the first part of the
curve is a short
and after all you have the budget and
the team to get the first delivery
completed
however subsequent adoption can be
harder
and is often predicated on the success
of the early deliveries
in our experience customers who get into
production quickly
with something core to their business
are able to maintain and build stronger
momentum
on the platform and are much more
successful at achieving their goals of
speed
and agility over the long term careful
selection of your first project
will help you achieve this we like to
offer
three essential components that will
improve your chances for success
we think about these three
characteristics for selecting
your first project ready
rewarding and relevant let's explore
these characteristics in more detail
completing your first delivery quickly
with something core to your business
gives your program its strongest start
ready
means selecting an mvbo that allows for
that quick delivery
this means ideally avoiding items that
may require significant back-end
refactoring
that might take many months to complete
or
avoiding the items that have
dependencies on other programs of work
they'll take also months to complete for
example
an api for a mobile app refresh planned
months in the future
rewarding means ensuring your mvbo is a
strong showcase
and demonstrates value to the
organization ideally
value here means recognizable value to
your business leadership
that is a real and intangible impact to
your bottom line
you may be enabling a new line of
revenue or increased engagement with
customers
the best examples are measurable with
respect to the end user of your business
for example for retail this might be
measured in
sales for insurance it might be measured
in handling time for new claims
processing
a great example will also provide
bragging rights for your sponsor
you might want to deliver something that
allows your leadership to widely share
the success to help bring attention
the new capability that was delivered
quickly
relevant means that the initial mvbo is
a good use case for api management
this could be reducing friction for
developer adoption
through better self-service developer
portals
or measuring usage through analytics
that allow
traffic to be tied back to the business
drivers starting by selecting an mvbo
that is ready rewarding and relevant
will provide for the strongest start
in a way that sets your program up for
sustained momentum
and long-term success i like to share a
couple real world
customer stories that show how starting
with a good mvbo
led to that success long term the first
is a multinational bank operating out of
the middle east
wanting to demonstrate the ability to
get new products to market quickly
furthermore their leadership we're
looking to showcase
product innovation the project team
responsible for deploying
apogee decided to start with a handful
of pretty straightforward apis one was
an identity api to track
user authorization an account api with
the ability to set
savings interest rates and a wrapper for
the apple watch api that could pull
step count information the team was
available to launch
a new savings account that linked to
your apple watch such that the further
you walked
the higher your interest rate pretty
nice huh
importantly they were able to launch
this new product in just 12 weeks
way faster than the typical time frames
for product development for this bank
that's even better our second example
comes from retail
this well-established brick and mortar
retailer was looking to defend against
online
only new market entrants by successfully
launching their own e-commerce store
instead of trying to do too much at the
start they began with simple use cases
that were core to enabling the
e-commerce business
including inventory and customer
information
after securing success and confidence by
delivering on these early use cases
they found other business leaders in the
organization coming to the api team
to create and access similar tools over
time
this led to a build out of a full set of
capabilities towards establishing
a federated ecosystem where distributed
sellers
could do business with customers via the
api powered e-commerce platform
best of luck with your first project if
you want more information
please check out the community for
ebooks articles
and other related topics thank you for
watching